we are learning more about tomorrow's
highly anticipated anticipated testimony
to Congress from former FBI director
James Comey who was fired by President
Trump a source close to command tells
CBS News the director was uncomfortable
meeting alone with the president when we
spoke to Attorney General Jeff Sessions
about it after mr. Trump made requests
that Comey believed were in a print
appropriate and there are also new signs
this morning that sessions and the
president are at odds over the handling
of the Russia investigation Margaret
Brennan is at the White House with all
the news this morning Margaret good
morning good morning well the spotlight
on that Russia investigation is making
it harder for President Trump to
accomplish his legislative goals and it
serves as a distraction for an embattled
White House I worship her president
Trump made no mention of acrimony toward
fired FBI director James Comey who is
set to testify to Congress on Thursday
even joking with Republican lawmakers
about the rising profile of his
son-in-law Jared Kushner Jerry Jones
actually become much more famous than me
I'm a little bit upset about that the
ribbing drew comparisons to president
Trump singling out of been FBI director
Comey just two days after his
inauguration he's become more famous
than me a source close to Comey tells
CBS News that the president's outreach
amid an ongoing FBI investigation made
the former FBI director so uncomfortable
that he asked Attorney General Jeff
Sessions not to leave him alone in a
room with mr. Trump in commis view the
president's request for him to drop the
probe into fired National Security
Advisor Michael Flynn's contacts with
Russia was inappropriate but a source
says Comey will stick to the facts and
will not accuse the president of trying
to obstruct justice you others can say
that their work matters so much
tensions developed between President
Trump and his Attorney General after
sessions recused himself from the Russia
investigation a decision that paved the
way for special prosecutor Robert Muller
to take over the probe White House press
secretary Sean Spicer refused to say
whether mr. Trump still had confidence
in
I said I have not had a discussion with
them on the question back in May Spicer
said the same thing about Comey just
hours before he was fired I have no
reason to believe I haven't asked him so
I don't I have not asked the president
since the last time we spoke about this
sessions deputy rod Rosenstein as well
as the Director of National Intelligence
dan coates will speak to the Senate
Intelligence Committee today and Gail
Coates released a statement saying that
he has never felt any pressure from the
President to influence any investigation
all right that will certainly come up
today thank you very much Margaret